- Lightning, fire, all of it.
I want all of it.
- You wanna have all the powers?
- I want all of it.
- I love Sailor Moon.
- I babysat for years,
and literally every cent
of that money went to Sailor
Moon gear and paraphernalia.
- I can't think of any
other show where the entire
cast of superheroes is all women.
- Teamwork was so
important to Sailor Moon,
but it was teamwork that
was very woman-centered.
- I would absolutely love to see a Latino
character added into the canon.
I'd love to see it now.
- It would be really
great to see a black girl
as a Sailor Scout, like yeah, afro puffs
and stuff, I think that'd
be really cute, actually.
- What kind of weapon do you want?
- Really long hair that
I could turn into a whip.
I kinda wanted to be
wearing like high boots
that have like a killer
heel that could just like.
(screeches)
- A killer heel.
What kind of super power
have you always wanted?
- Some sort of power with my hair,
like if I just had big hair,
I could hold stuff in it,
I don't know, like a
ball of energy and throw
it at someone.
- (laughs) Hold something in your hair.
- Yeah.
- And what would you say
your weapon would be?
- You mean like a sword or
something, is that what you mean?
- It can be whatever you want.
It can be whatever you want.
- No.
- I was thinking a pen, like a pen that--
- (gasps) The pen is
mightier than the sword.
- [Neetu] Yeah.
- I definitely want a scepter.
10 percent flirty, but
like 90 percent bad-ass.
- [Neetu] Why not 100 percent bad-ass.
- No, we gotta be real.
We're recreating me, not the ideal woman.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Do you
want to close your eyes?
- Can I look?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Oh my god.
It's so cute.
- (screams)
(laughs)
- Holy (beeps).
What a fierce bad-ass bitch.
- I look like Bat Girl. (laughs)
- And I like that she
got the two piercings.
They're one of the characters
that I celebrate the most.
- She even has my like angry face frown.
- I've got a star in my hair.
And I can throw it and kill someone.
- Pug scepter, yes.
- If you are out there,
animators, you should get
on this right now.
- But I think that would be great
for a little girl to see a superhero
that has afro puffs, just like hers.
- Looking at myself
painted as a superhero,
really fulfills a part of my childhood
that was always a little empty.
- There's something so cool about seeing
yourself so perfectly
represented, as like this
bad-ass superhero that makes me want
to aspire to like be that.
- The way she's springing to life.
She's got these two weapons,
but also the smile on her face,
like just because she's
fierce and powerful
doesn't mean that she's
any less beautiful.
Celebrating those things, and showing
that it can be married,
is one of the greatest
strengths of Sailor Moon.
In fact it makes them more beautiful,
the more powerful they are.